The DC Extended Universe might be struggling
to find some critical success, but its movies
are still making a lot of money.
And Warner Bros. has more than a dozen — 16,
actually, for those keeping count — in various
stages of development right now.
So what do fans have to look forward to over
the next five or so years?
Let's crack the cover and find out.
Wonder Woman
It's been a long road, but director Patty
Jenkins' Wonder Woman movie is set to finish
a journey that many fans never thought would
arrive in theaters in June 2017.
DC's biggest female hero is long overdue for
her solo shot at big screen glory.
Thankfully, the early trailers from the film
look fantastic, and Gal Gadot's take on Diana
was one of the best things about Batman v
Superman: Dawn of Justice.
So, there's something to build on.
But there's been a cloud of negative buzz
surrounding the project, with some supposed
insiders claiming it's a mess.
For the sake of DC, and Wonder Woman fans
everywhere, we hope those rumors are far from
the truth.
Justice League
Zack Snyder's Justice League, set to hit theaters
in November, 2017, picks up in the wake of
Batman v Superman, and is reportedly having
its tone heavily retooled on the fly after
all the negative buzz from Batman v Superman's
overly grim tone.
It'll apparently follow Batman and Wonder
Woman as they look to assemble a team of heroes
to pick up the slack following Superman's
apparent "death" at the end of that film.
Considering it's not the Justice League without
Superman, we'd think it'll also feature that
guy's resurrection, too.
Aquaman
He's been the butt of jokes for years, but
James Wan's December 2018 Aquaman film looks
to finally bring some respect to the man who
talks to fish.
Casting burly Game of Thrones alum Jason Momoa
in the title role didn't hurt much, either.
The film will reportedly feature the classic
comic character Black Manta as the central
villain, and introduce audiences at large
to the wider world of Atlantis and the undersea
kingdom's culture.
It's a risky venture, but having Furious 7
director James Wan at the helm means if nothing
else, the action should at least be up to
snuff.
Shazam!
Warner Bros. has been prepping a Shazam! movie
for awhile now, and all we really know is
that Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson is attached
to play the villain, Black Adam.
Outside of that, there hasn't really been
a lot of momentum.
We don't know a lot about the story, and the
filmmakers have been coy about just how much
it will, or won't, connect to the DCEU at
large.
Outside of Johnson and a projected release
date of April, 2019, there's been no word
on casting — like who will play teenager
Billy Batson or his super-powered alter ego.
Whoever it is, the pressure will be on to
actually match up against Johnson as the big
bad.
Green Lantern Corps
No casting has been announced for this film
about superpowered space cops, but the studio
is actively working this one behind the scenes,
with a script from David Goyer and Justin
Rhodes on the way.
Despite the fact that it's three years out,
Warner Bros. is bullish, with a release date
of July 2020 already locked.
No word on the plot, but it's been described
as "Lethal Weapon in space."
Which, you know, sounds pretty much perfect.
We also know it'll focus on two different
characters: the popular Green Lantern characters
Hal Jordan, who was previously played by Ryan
Reynolds, and John Stewart.
Bringing Stewart is a wise move.
He's a fan favorite, and getting him in the
mix will help this film stand apart from the
previous, critically panned Green Lantern
flick.
Hey, it can't really be worse, right?
"Yeah, that part I heard about."
The Flash
Pretty much the only thing we know about DC's
Flash feature set for 2020 is that it'll star
Ezra Miller as the big-screen Barry Allen.
Aside from that, everything is in flux.
Director Rick Famuyiwa was originally attached,
but he left the project in late 2016 due to
creative differences.
It's been months, and, as of the making of
this video, the studio is still looking to
fill the directorial void.
Considering all the creative problems DC has
had behind the scenes, the split from Famuyiwa
isn't a great sign, but, Warner Bros. looks
to be taking its time to try and get this
one right, which is smart.
As the CW's hit Flash series has proven, there's
an audience out there that loves this character.
The pressure is on to get them out from in
front of their TVs, and into theaters.
Cyborg
By the time Cyborg shows up in his solo movie,
fans should be pretty familiar with him.
Ray Fisher's version of the character will
have co-starring roles in Justice League and
The Flash, and as much as Warner Bros. loves
cameos, it wouldn't be surprising to see him
pop up elsewhere, too.
We already got a fleeting glimpse at Cyborg
thanks to those handy Lex Luthor YouTube videos
in Batman v Superman.
But we'll presumably learn more about him
over the next few films.
Since the character will have been thoroughly
introduced by the time this one rolls around,
it stands to reason it probably won't be an
origin story.
Or if it is, at least it won't be the entire
focus of the story.
The Batman
Batman is easily the cash cow of the DC universe,
and Warner Bros. seems keen to get a standalone
movie made starring Ben Affleck as the new
version of the Dark Knight.
Affleck has been developing the project for
awhile, but it was recently announced he wouldn't
be directing.
Instead, he'll be focusing on his work in
front of the camera.
By moving Affleck out of the director's chair
and hiring Matt Reeves, it seems the studio
might be trying to get the project made sooner
than later.
Meanwhile, Affleck has said numerous times
that he wasn't in a huge hurry to get it done.
Little is known about the project, aside from
the fact that it'll likely feature Joe Manganiello
as key villain Deathstroke.
But, with the project getting a revamp, who
knows if Deathstroke will even survive the
rewrites?
Dark Universe
Sometimes known as Justice League Dark during
development, this project is set to focus
on the mystical side of the DCEU, featuring
characters such as John Constantine, Swamp
Thing, Deadman, and Zatanna.
Edge of Tomorrow's Doug Liman signed on to
direct in 2016, though there hasn't been much
information since then.
Considering the success Marvel had with Doctor
Strange, it stands to reason Warner Bros.
will be keen to get this one off the bench
soon.
Hopefully they'll tap Matt Ryan play John
Constantine on the big screen, because let's
be honest — the dude is perfect.
Gotham City Sirens
David Ayer's follow-up to Suicide Squad looks
to be this Harley Quinn-centric spinoff, as
opposed to a straight-up sequel.
Ayer is set to reteam with Margot Robbie for
the film, which will focus on Harley Quinn
and several other female heroes and villains
across the DC Comics canon.
No word on which characters will show up,
though ladies like Catwoman and Poison Ivy
seem likely.
Between this and the Wonder Woman movie, DC
has an excellent opportunity take the edge
over Marvel Studios in female-led superhero
fare, which could be a huge move for a studio
playing catch-up.
The movies just, you know, need to be good.
Justice League 2
Warner Bros. originally penciled this one
in for 2019, but it's since been bumped to
an unspecified date to clear out some space
for The Batman.
This one might not be locked in anywhere at
the moment, but of all the projects at the
far end of DC's master plan, it stands to
reason another Justice League is one of the
most bankable.
The Avengers has become a flagship franchise
for Marvel, and DC is looking to leverage
Justice League the same way.
Of course, there are a lot of standalone movies
and spinoffs to make in the meantime.
Man of Steel 2
All logic points to Superman featuring in
the Justice League film in some way, but despite
Man of Steel formally kicking off this shared
cinematic universe, the studio doesn't seem
to be in a major hurry to give him another
solo adventure.
The cast has confirmed a script is in the
works, but with so many other movies on the
docket, you have to think it could be years
until they actually get around to making this
one.
There's also the questions of how DC wants
to treat the character in the long term, and
whether or not they've learned anything from
the Hulk over at Marvel.
Both are insanely powerful characters, and
both typically work a bit better in an ensemble.
Much like Marvel pulls Hulk out to play in
the big movies, DC could follow the same playbook
with Superman.
Suicide Squad 2
A proper Suicide Squad sequel is in development,
but there's been no word on when it'll actually
hit the big screen.
Despite anemic reviews, the first film still
made a whole lot of money — and introduced
characters like Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn,
and Will Smith's Deadshot, both of whom will
almost certainly pop back up in the DCEU down
the line.
Suicide Squad is a semi-proven commodity within
the universe, which is significant.
But with Warner Bros. high on getting Gotham
City Sirens off the ground, this one could
stay on the back burner for awhile.
Deadshot
Will Smith is one of Hollywood's biggest stars,
so it's no surprise Warner Bros. is looking
to spin him off with a film focused on his
Suicide Squad character Deadshot.
Outside of Ben Affleck, Smith is arguably
the biggest star in the DCEU — so it's only
a matter of time until they get him suited
back up for another fight against Batman.
At this point, the project seems to be in
very early development, and there's no word
on where it might eventually fit in the overall
schedule.
Black Adam
This one has everyone a bit confused.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson has been attached
to co-star in a Shazam movie for years, playing
the villain Black Adam.
And we recently heard Warner Bros. is now
developing a full-fledged Black Adam spinoff
film, which will split the character off into
more of an antihero.
Johnson explained the plans to reporters:
"We're building our world that way, and then
we can come together at some point."
It remains to be seen how DC will juggle a
two-pronged side section of the DCEU while
they're still trying to establish the main
universe.
Lobo
Word leaked in 2016 that Warner Bros. is looking
to bring the space bounty hunter Lobo to the
DCEU.
And Wonder Woman writer Jason Fuchs is reportedly
working on the script now.
The studio has also signed Brad Peyton, who
helmed the earthquake movie San Andreas, to
direct.
A film based on Lobo has kicked around development
hell for the better part of a decade, with
Sherlock Holmes' Guy Ritchie attached to make
one as far back as 2009.
Despite the false starts, this new project
is apparently a fresh take on the character.
Considering the success Fox and Marvel have
had with Deadpool, Lobo could be a foul-mouthed
sweet spot for DC to get in on the action.
Maybe.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!